[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je suis heureuse heureuse
heureuse d'être là c'est beau de voir
tous ici enfin tous cent cinquante 150
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un beau bébé
quand même bon maintenant il va falloir
trouver une solution il faut les rouvrir
ses salles de cinéma le plus vite
possible
alors moi je vais donc remettre le césar
de la meilleur espoir féminin la
meilleure espoir féminine mais non non
ça va pas une espoir une espace pas
français c'est un l'espoir en plus une
espoir ce fait pouvoir
on n'est pas des poires manquerait plus
qu'ils n'en n'ont donc pardon je
recommence je vais donc remettre le
césar du meilleur espoir féminine ah ben
non mais ah ben non ça va pas non plus a
féminine sept féminin qu'il faut dire
parce que espoir masculin
oui mais c'est masculin féminin en fait
non je sais plus bon en allemand au
moins ils ont tu as le thé neutre voilà
bon das meilleur espoir
bon ben alors je vais remettre le césar
das meilleur espoir féminin
alors j'ai un mot pour pour chacune
d'entre vous des mots féminins confiance
patience persévérance insouciance